[Musique]
bonjour les petits enfants ouf j'ai bien
cru que nous ne reviendrions jamais beau
jeu bien eu peur
et moi aussi nous sommes montés sur une
fusée et nous sommes allés jusque sur la
lune une salle vite aux ja bio ne plus y
penser
alors à langres aux ours s'est passé
remet toi de tes émotions mirabel et
p'tit louis t'attendre descend vite les
retrouver plus une europe là j'aime
mieux mon échelle comportant pas pour
vous dire mirabel oui tu crois que
grosso ce voyage encore avec des ballons
belges espèrent bien le voir si les
voilà la wii à lui les enfants
oui j'en ai marre ce point journée en
gros noms
sa fin une annonce que la vitre est en
voyage
tutu par crouch ne m'en parlez pas on
était à califourchon sur une fusée elle
allait vite levé vous avez dit la libye
elle est gentille et tu nous a rapporté
quelque chose mais oui quelque chose de
très mignon montrer notre vive attendait
il va arriver avec sa fusée
mais qu'est ce qu'un grand cosmonaute
ah le voilà chantante sa fusée
[Musique]
c'est un petit charles x heures monsieur
le cosmonaute
je vous présente mirabel et voici petit
louis bonjour cosmo et cosmo cosmonautes
ont dû dont c'est bien compliqué son nom
[Musique]
ce n'est pas son nom au regard du porte
une médaille autour du cou
hassan a créé ici et là nous ne voyons
voyons mi mai oui minet 1
j'aime bien ça commence à venir
oula tf1 sûrement et je crois bien que
ce chaton aventureux sera ravi de rester
quelques jours chez vous pour se reposer
et boire du bon lolliot tu vas voir va
bien le soigner nous nous amène à un
appétit minet qui niche à l'ombre les
enfants il est tard et moi j'ai besoin
de dormir pour récupérer mes fatigue on
laisse mines et à un boire son lait et
on va au dodo
[Musique]
et
il en a 23 ans j'ai dû aller voir la
lune nous vous raconterons notre voyage
et l' aventure de mines et un demain car
à présent il faut dormir
[Musique]
bonne nuit les enfants à demain bonne
nuit pauvre gros yeux fatigués temps
bien fait pour eux unity louis fauny
mirabel liminaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit petit louis bonnet petite
mirabelle bonne nuit tous les enfants
demain nous vous raconterons comment
nous avons rencontré ce petit chat dans
la lune et toutes nos aventures pendant
ce voyage
qu'est ce qui se passe là c'est le
nounours qui bâille
alan gross ours allons vite nous coucher
car moi aussi je suis fatigué nouvelle
peu chaude ou par trop gorge bordeaux
revenait à demain un peu bas
[Musique]
e
oh